i'm gonna tell all i'm gonna say what
everyone's thinking at home
it's
unfortunate that we kind of got to this
point goddess villain goddess villain i
thought you know we had this bond but
like hearing him tonight he seems like a
stranger to me honestly a reality check
for you and you lack the self-awareness
to even know that you're doing something
wrong i've let shay go a long time ago i
think you're all beautiful i'm not
attracted to all of you unfortunately
the only one i'm attracted to is vanessa
and it you know and i wish i wasn't yep
shake had no filter and no apologies at
the reunion in fact a source tells e.t
what we saw was a watered-down version
and shape was quote off the rails but
nick and vanessa were quick to bring the
33 year old veterinarian back to reality
i think you were on if i may the wrong
show it's nature baby we're animals
we're animals no you treat animals we're
human beings
i think it ended with uh
i don't want to talk to you again kind
of dramatic ending and i was just like
i'm like okay the current status between
me and shake is kind of we're just
acquaintances and i wish the best for
him in life i can't wait to like
get away from this fake group of people
on social media it appears shakes fully
embraced his turn as the season's
villain i'm not sorry
i'm not sorry shakes now ex-deepti might
have avoided disaster and may have new
love brewing with another cast member
kyle the biggest regret is i
i should have
i should have asked deepti to marry me
hey i would love that happy to
facilitate
my number two person from the pods was
kyle
and i've really gravitated towards him
and
he's like really my best friend and no
matter if he let like
resonates into a relationship or not
like i just know that he has my back and
i have his other things we learned at
the reunion streaming now on netflix
shayna has moved on from kyle and shane
my relationship status is i am in a
relationship and the two married couples
are still happily together we actually
threw a party at my mom's house where we
had a lot of the cast members come out
um we played laser tag we wrote atvs
we played beer pong i lost but no it's
like so good to have other people who
like actually know what it feels like to
go through this because no one else in
the world does i have no regrets overall
i think i'm pretty proud of myself from
how i handle things i was able to to get
everything out of this that i was
putting in and i have no regrets with
anything that i did shane however does
have regrets that led to this moment i
do
but i don't
trust my idea i don't think about that
and go over to my head differently it
was very tough seeing her the feelings
got brought back up and i definitely
just wanted to hug her
and
yeah she was beautiful it sounds stupid
to say a fight changed everything but i
think it just
for us it was kind of a wake-up call i
was a bit nervous you know
seeing shane again it has been a few
months and you know obviously the
feelings um there
you know are still pretty pretty raw
let's just say that that that night
definitely solidified why it didn't work
out
[Music]
you